we do have good news for the president
according to his doctors
well he is experiencing zero covert 19
symptoms on a speedy road to recovery
and we can hope and pray that continues
for everybody that contracts this well
invisible enemy
apparently many uh new yorkers though
they have been brainwashed by the media
mob and thinks something conspiratorial
is at play
joining us now with the full report all
hannity 2020 election correspondent our
very own lawrence jones lj what do we
got tonight
hey good evening sean as you noted the
president is back at the white house
recovering from the coroner virus
but he's not finished with his agenda in
fact he's going
all in after months of negotiations with
the democrats for covet relief
he announced today that he would be
ending those negotiations
until after the election the president
says his now
his focus now will all be on his supreme
court nominee
and to get that nominee to get confirmed
but some don't believe that the
president
ever had kovachon they think it was all
a hoax
watch it looks like he's doing pretty
well now
though but he still has covered but yeah
i'd still be a little cautious
yeah i mean if i ran into someone that i
knew i copied
two days ago and was in the hospital i'd
probably probably want a little
separation from
sometimes i wonder if it's just a ploy
you think it's fake
to get people to vote for him to get
people to feel sorry for him
you never know you never know some
people said it was a hoax do you believe
it
no you don't believe it i don't believe
that they
if they're trying to find any reason
they can to pick on them and this is
just another one but why would he
pretend
to have kovalev maybe later on he'll
have an explanation then you you piece
two and two together and you'll see like
oh this is why he
he said he had coronavirus we need to
find something to reunite on
and if the president is sick we all as
citizens should be coming together
regardless of not whether or not we like
his political stance
a healthy president is a healthy country
sean as you can see it looks like that
brother at the end was the only person
that had a
bit of common sense saying that we need
to unify behind the president and wish
him well
i know i am he's in my prayers all right
lj thank you so much